[Music]  my name is cardi B my friends call me  Barela  [Laughter]  from the signature red gloves and black  and white hair to this adorable  Dalmatian cardi be completely transforms  into karela deville for Halloween I will  be performing on my lay the bodek yellow  singer attended Bacardi's dressed to be  free event in NYC Monday night where she  later lit up the stage performing her  hit single dressed as the Disney villain  when the club's district party and AI  gets paid to speak the newly-engaged  star who said yes to boyfriend offset  dished on the romantic concert proposal  most of my family members were there my  friends were there people like so  surprised me son and here's what cardi  says she wants for her wedding day I  don't know how my dress is gonna be but  I really want my bridesmaids to wear red  [Music]